- In a world full of Zoom calls
when people can only see our top half,
Winnie the Pooh style,
how can we still be glamorous
while sitting at home on our
couches or working from home?
Well, our next guest has that answer.
He has designed some of
the most iconic gowns ever
and he's one of my favorite people,
let alone mentors on "Project Runway."
Please welcome Christian Siriano.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
- You look divine.
- I do you, you think so?
- Thank you.
Okay, so how did the quarantine affect you
because when people could
not get their hands on masks,
there you were at your atelier,
making it with everyone
and Cuomo deemed your
business an essential business
so they could make PPE and open.
- I tweeted him, I begged him.
I was like, we wanna help,
so I was tryin' to keep
my kind of small business in New York,
but then also do something great.
So it all worked out for everybody.
I will say masks are quite a challenge.
We've donated almost a million.
- Wow, everything you're
doing, I admire, I applaud
and I already loved you,
but that just put you into
superhero stratosphere.
Now can we do a little
quarantine fashion show?
- Yeah.
- [Drew] What should we do?
Should we bring out Jennifer?
- Let's bring first look.
Come on.
(Drew laughs)
- This is all about, this
is like no fear have fun,
kind of like sexy pajamas on bottom
and then like some glamor on the top.
- [Drew] It's a little
Samantha Jones on the bottom.
- [Christian] Samantha
Jones on the bottom.
- But it's giving me Betsy
Johnson vibes on the top.
- Old school, I love a dangle earring.
I wish earrings were all at the shoulder.
I think that's just like
a hit and headbands,
I don't always love them,
but I think for a Zoom call, why not?
- I have to say, I think you
look absolutely beautiful,
Jennifer, really.
- Hair and makeup, a pink lip.
Why not a pink lip at 10:00
AM for your friends on Zoom?
- I know. I was hoping my
friends were having a cocktail
at 9:00 AM on premiere day.
I was like, is that weird?
So I a hundred percent, but you're right.
Accessories make such a huge difference.
Now, why did you need an outfit, Jennifer?
- Well, so many people
nowadays are working at home
and they're doing trainings
and meetings with their bosses
and clients online,
so you still have to look good
at least from the waist up
'cause you can't be going
on with your employer
with bun in your hair and sweatpants on.
- I gotta tell you,
you look like you're straight off holiday.
Thank you, Jennifer. Seriously.
- You look gorgeous.
- Okay, Peyton, will
you please come on out?
- Okay, I love this look.
- [Drew] Peyton, are those my shoes?
- They probably are.
- I'm not kidding. I
wore those to work today.
I'm pretty sure.
By the way I was so
obsessed with the bottom
because of course I'm like, oh,
moccasins with like a faux--
- That is not the look.
We're not looking at that.
Waist up.
- I know, but of course that's
what I'm gravitating towards,
but now my eyes raised
and you are all class.
Now, why did you need an outfit?
- Well, I'm violently single, Drew,
so I am using this for a speed
dating online through Zoom.
- The guys at home are really
struggling. I feel you.
And the thing is, I think it's
more of a conversation here.
We have plaids and I don't know
gingham and the whole look.
It's the vest.
- Well, I have to say,
I do miss the era of
bowler hats and jackets
and a little bit of a more
etiquette style to our fashion.
- Dress to impress.
- [Drew] So I think
that you look fantastic.
- Speed date away.
- Therese, will you please come out here?
Oh my god.
Again, Christian, why am I
going straight to the bottom?
- No, that is not how you
want to live your life,
but look, look how comfortable,
but how glamorous on top.
Volume and texture, hoops. I love it all.
- Christian, you have a tip,
like don't wear soft fabrics
and maybe go for a little
more tailored on a Zoom look?
- I just think because
you're in this small screen,
it's like, you don't want too much,
it's like much is about
like where's the texture,
where's the glamor.
If it's chiffon and
wrinkly, it's not working.
- I have to say, I am so inspired
because I get to dress up at work.
I'm even extra lazy in my real life.
I'm always in a really threadbare,
old vintage cotton. T-shirt,
so now that I'm gonna
step up my home game.
Now, Therese, why did you need an outfit?
- Well, I'm wearing this for a
good friend's birthday party,
so we're sharing recipes, cocktails,
and the best part is, I don't
have to wear heels or drive.
- And is it at night or is it a day?
- It's at night.
- Uh huh, okay, I think
that changes the game.
- Yeah, this is an evening look.
- I love being in your
world in your clothes.
- I'm in your world.
- Finally 'cause I've
been living in your world
and I wanna do so many
things with you, Christian.
You guys thank you so much,
Jennifer, Peyton, Therese.
Thank you to our beautiful
quarantined fashion models.
You are bringing it and
Christian, I love you.
(audience cheers)
- Love you.
(upbeat music)